معكم جميعا
ومعكم نحتفل بليله ميلاد من غزه من كنيسه
ع المقدسه للاتين ونطلب من فر المغاره ان
يعطي لنا السلام الذي جلبه لنا من اكثر من
2000 عام بصراحه ميلاد المسيح بشكل لنا
الفرح والسعاده بمجيئه لكن للاسف الشديد
السنه كانت الاجواء غير طبيعيه
الكل بيعرف الظروف الصعبه اللي بعيشها
قطاع
غزه من شهداء من
جرحى من مفقودين بصراحه لحد هذه
[موسيقى]
اللحظه
وبي العيد هذا يختلف عن الاعياد السابقه
هذا عيد تحت حصار تحت حرب تحت دمار تحت
شهداء شهداء راحوا لنا في داخل الحرم
الكنيسي يعني زوجتي وبنتي اللي راحوا
في وابنائي ابني وانا ومرا ابني اولاد
ابني تصابوا بنحن مش حاملين اسلحه ولا
حاملين
ضد الجيش
الاسرائيلي
ط
الي
حت
السما فالنا حزن كبير في
قلوبنا تحت الحرب وتحت القصف ونحنا اسينا
كثير وبنتمنى من العالم كله انه يوقف
معنا وناشد كل العالم انه يساعدنا ويساعد
العالم العربي كله والشعب الفلسطيني اسى
كثير من حروب ومن اهوال نا سنين والنا عمر
بنقاس بنتمنى انه يحل السلام علينا